frightening situation in texas where a
woman was taken into custody after
firing a gun in an airport the suspect
was the only person her police say she
fired a weapon near the ticket counter
at dallas love field airport nicole
nielsen of our station ktvt has the
story
this is the moment police shot the
suspect at dallas love field airport
bringing monday's harrowing ordeal to an
end almost as soon as it started our
officer engages the suspect strikes her
in the lower extremities she's taken
into custody and is currently at
parkland hospital authorities say it
began around 11 a.m when the suspect
later identified by police as
37-year-old porsha adufua walked into
the airport terminal went inside a
restroom and emerged with a firearm she
was kind of saying her husband was
having an affair of some sort and
actually was going to blow the effing
airport up bystanders took cover as
gunfire erupted and his word made its
way across the airport people just
started running like crazy some visitors
locked down
while others were escorted out for
safety the faa instituted a ground stop
for planes that lasted hours and
southwest airlines which uses dallas
love field as a hub canceled 90 flights
active shooters at airports do occur
from time to time and most of the time
they'll start in the public area so
everybody needs to be watchful jeff
price is an aviation security expert who
once served as the assistant security
director at denver international airport
really it's it's not a matter of being
paranoid all the time it's simply a
matter of being aware of your
surroundings being aware of your
circumstances the
the thing to add about this is that it
can occur anywhere
now texas state law does allow gun
owners with a concealed carry license to
have their firearms in this section of
the terminal but police have yet to
comment on whether or not the suspect
had such a license gail
nicole thank you so much that's such a
frightening situation then you hear the
reason is because she suspected her
husband was having an affair
so that caused her to kind of lose her
mind she was very lucky that she's still
alive i'm glad nobody else was seriously
very lucky yeah because you saw those
officers moving in on her weapons drawn
yeah
better way to handle that